[Musica]
quando parliamo di disabilità di cosa
parliamo Qual è la prima immagine che vi
viene in mente così senza pensarci
troppo
Amen Se aveste fatto questa domanda nove
anni fa sarebbe venuta in mente questa
Forse questa
Oggi invece mi viene in mente questa
in mezzo in questi nove anni c'è la mia
storia con la fondazione Paideia che è
una storia lavorativa Certo però è anche
un po' una storia d'amore
perché ho la fortuna di fare un lavoro
che amo tantissimo Io sono una
fandreiser ma soprattutto la fortuna di
essermi innamorata della causa per la
quale lavoro che aiutare i bambini con
disabilità e le loro famiglie
sapete prima di incontrare Paideia io
non conoscevo davvero la disabilità non
l'avevo mai vissuta sulla mia pelle in
famiglia o tra i miei amici e non mi ero
mai chiesta che cosa significhi davvero
vivere con una disabilità o accanto ad
una persona con disabilità
ne avevo un'immagine un po' stereotipata
sì lo ammetto
Forse perché a differenza della malattia
credo ma la disabilità se non la vivi
direttamente se non ce l'hai vicina
onestamente pensi un po' che sia
qualcosa che che non ti riguarda Almeno
per me era così non so se così anche per
voi
Poi però in questi anni sono successe
tante cose e ho imparato tante cose
Ho imparato che quando nasce un bambino
con disabilità le reazioni possono
essere molto diverse
ci si può trovare spersi non sapere
quale strada prendere Si può provare
rabbia colpa vergogna disperazione
ci si sente soli spesso
qualcuno reagisce con forza qualcun
altro invece ha bisogno di tempo per
fare i conti con le proprie paure con il
proprio dolore
ognuno sapete reagisce a modo suo vive
la disabilità a modo suo e ho imparato
che questa è la prima cosa da rispettare
Ho imparato che la disabilità quando
arriva non colpisce solo il bambino ma
tutta la sua famiglia
colpisce i suoi genitori Certo ma anche
suo fratello sua sorella e i suoi nonni
quella diagnosi cambia per sempre la
vita di tutti
Sembra scontato forse detto così Però vi
assicuro che non lo è
pensate per esempio che cosa significhi
essere il fratello o la sorella di un
bambino con disabilità
pensate quali sfide sono chiamati ad
affrontare questi ragazzi fin da subito
fin da quando sono bambini
Io onestamente non ci avevo mai pensato
prima
Eppure tutti quando si trovano a fare i
conti con la disabilità possono avere
bisogno di aiuto e allora forse è
proprio prendersi cura di tutte le
persone coinvolte bambini genitori
fratelli sorelle quella chiave di volta
che permette di fare la differenza nella
vita delle persone
sapete
La verità è che esiste un prima e un
dopo l'arrivo della disabilità
prima c'era la vita Come tenere
immaginata
dopo c'è da ricostruire
ricostruire una nuova normalità
ed è difficile Certo però si può fare
soprattutto se accanto a te c'è qualcuno
che ti dice io ci sono non sei solo non
sei sola puoi contare su di me
e ho imparato che in quel dopo oltre
alle terapie alla riabilitazione a tutto
quello che potete immaginare c'è bisogno
di concedersi anche dei momenti di
leggerezza di benessere di svago di
bellezza
c'è bisogno di concedersi il diritto di
poter stare di nuovo bene
e di andare in vacanza al cinema al
museo a cena fuori di farsi nuovi amici
di cantare di nuovo a squarciagola in
macchina
immaginarsi in futuro
perché disabilità e felicità possono
Anzi devono stare insieme
C'è un'altra cosa che ho imparato in
questi anni per me è importante
e cioè che esistono disabilità visibili
che tutti riconosciamo a prima vista e
disabilità invisibili che spesso
scambiamo per qualcos'altro
ricordo ancora come mi sono sentito
ormai tanti anni fa quando una mamma ci
ha confidato un giorno di essere scesa
dal pullman 5 o 6 fermate prima del
previsto e di aver percorso l'ultimo
tratto di strada lungo a piedi
Perché suo figlio con un disturbo dello
spettro autistico
aveva avuto un momento di crisi proprio
sul pullman
e le persone intorno a lei avevano
iniziato a guardarla
a fissarla e qualcuno ha bisbigliare di
come quel bambino fosse maleducato
capriccioso non capendo evidentemente
quello che stava succedendo
mi ricordo perfettamente come mi sono
sentita quel giorno
e mi sono chiesta quante volte
inconsapevolmente il mio sguardo abbia
ferito
abbia giudicato abbia costretto qualcuno
a scendere dal pullman e mi sono chiesta
quanto in realtà la disabilità ci
riguardi tutte
sapete c'è stato un momento in cui ho
pensato di non essere la persona giusta
per salire su questo palco oggi a
parlarvi di disabilità ho pensato di non
averne il diritto che non aspettasse a
me farlo perché la disabilità a me non è
toccata in sorte
ma una parte della disabilità siamo noi
noi che non la viviamo direttamente noi
che non la conosciamo e per questo
indugiamo con lo sguardo noi che
proviamo paura o imbarazzo nel
relazionarci con una persona con
disabilità noi che pensiamo che non ci
riguardi
noi che facciamo sentire gli altri
diversi
però però ho imparato anche quanto sia
semplice Molto più semplice di quello
che si possa immaginare a volte
ribaltare la situazione
smettere di essere parte del problema e
iniziare a vivere in modo diverso
inclusivo in un mondo in cui la
disabilità
è vissuta per quello che è
normalità
o meglio come ci ha detto qualche tempo
fa una mamma la disabilità è qualcosa da
vivere e che si può vivere tutti insieme
Semplice no
lo so forse starete pensando
che non sia semplice affatto che non sia
possibile forse e lo capisco È normale
anch'io forse se non lo vedessi tutti i
giorni con i miei occhi non ci crederei
Eppure succede Non è utopia succede
proprio qui in un luogo reale aperto a
tutti ogni giorno un luogo in cui la
disabilità è vissuta come normalità Come
dovrebbe essere
e sapete cosa vedo oltre a questo tutti
i giorni
vedo tanti volontari che scelgono di
dedicare il proprio tempo libero a volte
addirittura le proprie vacanze ai
bambini e alle loro famiglie e in quella
relazione che nasce Grazie a loro vedo
tutta la spontaneità la forza la
meraviglia di una rivoluzione
una rivoluzione silenziosa che però sta
costruendo quel mondo inclusivo
possibile reale qui ora
e poi vedo centinaia di persone i nostri
sostenitori che scelgono di dire ai
bambini alle loro famiglie sono qui
siamo qui con voi non siete soli
io vedo quelli incondizionata amore per
l'essere umano che ci ha portato qui
oggi che si fa concreto e porta donare
donare per qualcuno che non si conosce
per aiutarlo ad affrontare un momento di
fragilità per fargli sentire il proprio
braccio
e poi vedo quell'abbraccio Quell'amore
che diventano forza la forza di tante
persone insieme unite da quel filo
invisibile che il dono E che permette di
realizzare progetti bellissimi che
cambiano la vita delle persone e in
fondo cambiano il mondo
lasciamo allora che la disabilità ci
riguardi tutti ci coinvolga tutti
Lasciamo che sia qualcosa come diceva
prima quella mamma che si può vivere
tutti insieme solo così insieme potremmo
rendere questo mondo un posto migliore
dove ognuno possa stare bene
Dove possiamo stare bene tutti grazie